thank you for coming to the attack no
I'm proving my Danish thank you tour
well Manaus was a very nice city in the
as far as I can remember the 50s at the
end of the 50s and the beginning of the
60s was a town with 300,000 haptens a
small town Brazil and with beautiful
small rivers that we call you gotta pace
he got pays it's a ninja name for it to
pee that means an arrow an arrow river
where eight ten small rivers in the city
but in with beautiful squares and
architectural Belle Epoque so opera
house which is there I don't know if it
was destroyed it yesterday but there is
a wonderful per house and and many
immigrants is my childhood was I my
friends were as you said we're
Brazilians but of several origins from
labor lube and for Italians but also
from people of Manaus but from the 70s
on this the city has been destroyed
because of the free zone I know how to
say yeah if there is there the boost
economy because my now in the rubber
time in the belly pockets you say was it
was if city built on the way
rubber and then when that declined about
40 50 years ago it was decided to make a
freezer on without Texas to attract
industry yes and actually legal has a
factory in in my knowledge building
making legal toys and stuff a lot of
factories in Manaus and a lot of growth
but well destroy that two million
habitants city its the but it's a very
missable now city with many problems and
all most of the old buildings la belle
epoque webstorage so it's not my seat
anymore I don't recognize the city of my
childhood but it's there in all your
novels it says this disease one of the
core of the of the novels of two
daughters I mean the destruction of of
the of the city and of the rainforest
also in the suburbs of one house there's
a scene in in national of the Amazon so
that's why all paradise are lost for our
innocence with a bang sometimes
sometimes with a bang and sometimes with
a whimper yes and in the spring of
nineteen sixty four you were 11 years
old 11 and a half years old and this is
where the novel this novel starts and
it's the time when the military seized
power in Brazil in the end of March
beginning of april nineteen sixty four
how did you experience the the military
coup and the dictatorship as a child
yeah I I have heard of this of the coup
d'etat when my my uncle was arrested
it's a pee
years and my grandmother cried and as
there was something wrong my family and
I asked you to my father what's going on
they said no you would not understand
now when and then when I was in high
school I I realized that something had
changing in Brazil Brazil and this was
my first my first vision of the of the
coup d'etat but in 64 there was no
there's not such a big repression as in
the 70 so at the end of the 60s it
groove worse and worse yes it became
worse and worse and can the idea of the
first general of the dealership was not
to to be tough with with the op open
open ends but then there was a turning
point inside the military elite of the
regime and well after something isn't
novel what happened in Brazil and then
in Chile and Argentina South America but
novels doesn't deal directly with this
question now it's another thing the
regime the coup d'etat is like a
background yes background yes not
directly but it begins at the same time
because these two boys meet each other
in the schoolyard when school resumes
after I s school has been closed down
during the coup and then school opens
again and these two boys happen to be in
the same class
we have high mundo o mundo & lavo who is
narek narrator but but mundo is
protagonist who is mundo this is a story
of a friendship and in a certain sense
they they are at the same time very
different but very very similar very
close wench other mundos up a part of
myself it's my other that's mundu goes
he flees goes to two real two barreling
to lon don he he wants to go away from
the provincial provincial life they did
it when I was 15 years old I I got out I
got out of my city alone my father said
me go black should go and i went to
brasilia horrible sit at that time said
violent and i lived to two years in
Brasilia and I couldn't bear the city
the atmosphere all day so I went some
pool and leave in ten years and became
an architect very bad accident in fact
and i left my profession and went to to
madrid and de madrid i started writing
my first novel it was important to to
see my country to get a distance of my
of my country and it was crucial for me
otherwise I perhaps I
I not have opportunity to write or to
think or to change my profession no it
was very important to go away why eyes
many many I was not a net an exile I was
an expat freight but problems happened
during the 70's my my life that's in one
of the other novels or others browse all
orphans of El Dorado someone says to his
son get out of the provinces the
provinces will destroy you head out
that's what happened and ends why did
you stop being an architect by the way
well my experience hasn't actually it
was terrible I made two projects they
were totally transform it one of them
was a house a beautiful a nice house
that became a Bordeaux a brother in my
house and the other one the pro cater
the changes completely my my idea and I
like to at that time to work with with
the social ah donzo Jose see Abdeslam
populist osho poplar yeah of the
enterprise and building dudes for the
house for the capo yeah but we couldn't
make projects no no because all the
projects were very very small small
houses and we gave up not only me but a
part of my generation but even today the
projects for people of houses are are
very very bad carriers
with no dignity so and I loved writing
since I was 12 years old it in Manaus I
wrote some poems in Brasilia also my
first poem was published in the
newspapers in Brasilia and in some power
I wrote some such stories I didn't
publish them I I polish I a small a
small book a poet appointment a book of
poetry it was completely forgot thanks
God it's not good and only in Europe I
started writing another and no one can
destroy like that like they destroyed
your houses I guess you know no one can
alter that those projects will destroy
them sometimes the editors Christine
till 18 did not translate them eyes but
my editor in Sao Paulo head well she's
very she's very nice very very smart and
you have to talk with that or we have to
change ideas and they think that the ads
or they they improve the tax sometimes
that tends off the ice door by the good
debt or can can improve for sure your
text and it's important all my books
were who were edited with my with my
opinions also know and I remember that
this book was a 400-page book and she
told me it's too long you have to cut 50
60 page that I did they did so you are
normally when you write for years but
at the end you you you you have to show
your texts to at someone yeah to our
friends and your enemies sometimes
through editor and well it has to go up
there you can't keep it forever but um
there's a lot of you in the high Moon do
or a lot of fun doing you should we hear
the beginning of the novel and we've
decided to do this in Portuguese and in
Danish so when I said before everything
was going to be in English that's not
quite true because Milton hatoum will
will read the very first page of the
novel in Portuguese I think it's
important that we all sort of get the
feeling how he writes what is his melody
what is his tone in his own language and
then I'll read senior produce Danish
translation okay can you translate in
Danish d the epigraph of good balance
Horza get leaves yeah in Danish yeah yes
sorry um summit as a little you know a
little not epitaph but a little a little
bottom epigraph yet a little epigraph a
motto in the beginning of the book is a
quotation from the great author Kimura
and Rosa ah yeah comma famine food I'm
Yakima Ennis this far and you will say
that too in Portuguese yeah oh it's easy
yeah elsword until I see so Joe true
guys that was nervous about this Leah
cottage a mundo Lombardo beco das
Gonzales Oh Jake entre hey Fujio
controllable ESO de centro de hielo y yo
soy sobre de chien de pais una carta
same data s [ __ ] my clinical
Copacabana
o'sullivan koozie coma kaligrafi amudha
tremula tiava lava dude my amigo en SE
escribe Maya vida de tras prof wrench
japonica Deza mais non posso nao consigo
hibiscus as palavras and mention o papel
Escriva hochwasser milagro cinta no
corpo sua da cunha ok silly poco en su
doofy la maison de hooch map as nuh as
palavras manwich epoch avez ete mo
hidden akala madrugada maisel/new kiss
adeje data noir the italian interesado
vici owns the place I storage mundo
media memoria confusion fog escondido
Ellen fancy elegant touch ID aguadas ok
Don condescension Otis joins this bozo
Tavares obeys naka bodice fighters in
Brazil Naropa la vida de vive que se la
Sol sin miedo como squeeze asesinas wrap
adentro yep akiza cada minuto African vo
para me cotton postage laundry's
obedience a stupid or have 0 le esta
pareja mundo tompa in lillis was
confined acidic le canceled as well as
the chief locked 40 cal who illustrated
I'm Dennis Francis that we spent sire
you play dough into Asia was currently
Nikki Copacabana meeting de lejos de
haan scratch the horrible vata orlag
million head it's in the post came with
you up for her up a far far into n mayor
can eat a kicking up Carson only one
ability clatter pop a pill tsk you and
listen it me harder America instance
with or he'll call them there there is
the student in a clever remark
inconsistency store one little ms net
thank you wear to the dog or some damn
Indian School ragnuk in data analysis
firm to give a bloody coup de italia
no to Orsino venom banana mundo see
store is a basement behind you for
trying the Bantam oh yeah Stella hence
if term attaining a note 8 hours kita
tidak man well suited verga entirely
perceived in Iowa favorability um flag
need you and focus guesses that will be
saw invention of a was a sale in fr you
can again into intense setting and
scouts him about cross-court for London
where you store made me stupid really
hello aqua as you see it's the better in
Danish these two characters lava is a
narrator but as in your other novels
I've noticed often the narrator is as a
character who is you know a little to
the side not not not so important a
character and not so important in the
family he he has a minor position in
some way and and relates tells about
things going on but mundo is is a
protagonist and his an artist he starts
out drawing in school draws caricatures
of the of the teachers and goes on to
become a painter and an artist and like
you went to Spain and to Paris in the
late 70s the 80s you went to the moon do
and his name is mundo is there a double
double meaning out there because his
name is world also of course yeah of
course but this aspiration to to be a
painter and artists was was suffocated
by his father hmm by his father and by
the fatherland yeah by the political
situation and there is no it's a tragic
destiny effect but all novels have
I have tragic destiny and and the other
one did the main narrator is a becomes a
lawyer a major lawyer and the praveen's
the provincial life but he writes the
story he writes the story he has the
memory the main problem I think that's
not not only this novel whoa-oh novels i
wrote this is how to how to deal with
the experience and language this for me
is a is a big challenge how Mike my own
experience of life of reading becomes a
language how memories become language
this is for me the very very important
the most important thing because memory
is just like imagination there's no
there's not such a difference between
her memory and imagination I'm just read
Bruce where memory begins and very much
nation ends all mixed up and and I could
not write about recent events it would
be impossible because I'm not
journalists to write about circumstance
so you have to wait the time yeah yeah
this novel ends in the early 80s I guess
doesn't it all the mid-80s approximately
takes a place over 20 years more or less
the the the president novel The Brothers
takes place from about nineteen forty
five to nineteen sixty-four to the
military coup and the most recent one
offensive eldorado is from about 19 10
to 19 second Lord warrior two nineteen
forty so you were actually described
most of the history of Brazil in the
20th century in in these three novels
but as you say it can't be recent events
it has to be history memories myths all
this yeah yeah it's like just like the
the worst of audience the memory you
have the key and this memory of the
experience that is important for me but
when you become old 90's i can so i can
write about the 90s and the 80's 90's
and but the number of books is not
important it's not not very important if
you write to write to ever i have a
friend in Brazil that he writes a book
each year mmm and asked me did you did
you read my book with which one you
Porsha I was going to read one of them
and you just finish another one yeah and
wife such a anxiety and I remember that
ba whole embarked when more is not 0 the
critics French critic he wrote the
history of Surrealism ax ax Hollen bath
about the crisis of literature but bahe
battery said there is no cries of litter
there are too much books well if we when
we go back to the title of the novel for
a moment the ashes yeah since ish to
north or ashes of the Amazon there's a
lot of symbolism in in ashes but there
are some some physical issues in the
book
too can you tell us a little bit about
what actions are we talking about this
afternoon I've wrote of it I've written
about the title in English embed in
English of course i wrote a king
sometimes you discover the book you want
to write when you find the title of
narrative to some extent that was that
was what happened with Caesar do large
which literally means ashes of the North
the north of the original Portuguese
title alludes to damage amazon region
but also to the curse and destiny of the
characters in other words it alludes to
a spanning compass to the disorientation
of various lives and had their tragic
destinies to paralyze shows frustration
or impasse life's turns to ashes so
there the lives of the characters thats
that the lives of the characters a part
of the rainforest there is a sin of
burning in the 70s and while the
ironically the north is is the contrary
the zuri a kind of disorientation of the
of the lives of the thinner area of the
lives so there's no the compass doesn't
work grilling yes it's it's a it's a
moral story of my of my generation yeah
in fact it was hard to be artists in
Brazil at that time it was hard to write
the publish to cause of the censorship
but i think that the novel goes beyond
the the historical frame and it's in
fact it's a familiar drama mmm that's I
wants to write yeah just because it's
also the destruction of a family the
fall of the house of
of genre and I'm going to uh yeah the
fall of the family to tell something
that's true was true for me because it
is the true of literature's not the
truth of science not even of
psychoanalysis which is very different
there is a link between psychologist and
literature of course my second let's try
to explain everything and the novel
cannot explain it should make questions
and it's a story of a desire a desire
that's not it's not completed its not
realized so the novel in fact is a story
of a desire that cannot cannot happen
there is an evil on job mmm somewhere to
interrupt the course of the life in love
a lot in life and there's a lot of
tension in the families a lot of tension
between father and son because the Sun
is a fright disappointment to his father
this goes for some of the other books
also in in orphans of El Dorado the the
protagonist courses well his mother dies
in childbed when he's born so he's the
course of his mother's death and his
father never stops letting him feel that
he killed his mother every day he makes
him feel that you're the cause of my
wife's death you're the cause of your
mother's death here a mundo to his
father Jean who is one big
disappointment is a mistake in error is
all this art rubbish wanting to become
an artist it's one big disappointment
and of course
father is a disappointment to tu mundo
he says it's not natural that a father
should love his dog more than his own
son but I guess he does he loves his dog
more but it's not autobiographical no no
no I never oh I never said that no but
you look at me as one no no no no no I
remember my poor father my mother I know
it's not talking about my father either
something is autobiographical but but
not slightly it's likely we have to
invent our biography in fact hmm that's
a good idea it's never too late to
Naugles never too late to have a happy
childhood there's a saying yeah exactly
yeah but but but I mean fathers and sons
is there in several of your novels right
is a classic it is subject of literature
yeah from Bozak from flow Barre from the
Russian writers the beg of you hmm yeah
and ballzack so it's but I try to link
the the familiar drama with the
historical context yeah expand to go
beyond this mmm well yeah and also
because as you said for a whole
generation it was the destruction of a
whole generation insert in some way what
what happened in the sixties and
seventies so you could say the father's
also destroyed something for the the
sun's turned their lives into ashes or
you know the Guardian the British
newspaper wrote in its review of this
novel it is partly a sense of waste and
destruction that gives this novel its
bitterness yet the defeat of a
generation and its ultimate moral
transcendence also lends it an epic
breath so there was in a way a
destruction of a generation or of
country but but there's also the
struction of the old city of manaus as
you told about the city as you write in
the other novel the city maiming itself
and refusing to acknowledge its past and
there's the fallacy of progress and
future you seem very skeptical about the
notions of progress and growth and
future totally totally you know your
motto the Brazilian Republic's motto is
order and progress of men dissolve reso
visit other disorders and I despite that
I I love Brazil it's a wonderful people
Brazilians the problem is our not all
but a part of our elites this is a big
problem and but his time will defeat
them mmm the bear barrels you think so i
think so i hope so elections and people
has to be educated you know a big
problem of the does not only violence
repression and censorship the
dictatorship they destroyed the public
education in brazil i studied in public
schools but those if the last generation
the study in a good public school and
after in 70s from 70 on public school
was destroyed so was completely
abandoned you have to get money to get
an education a lot of money yeah a lot
of money about one thousand dollar a MOS
have your your son your children each
one
in a private good private school can you
imagine one thousand dollar a month
that's what the elite and the middle
class in some Powell and real pays for
educate their children and another thing
that is very important when you study in
a public school you know all all the
people all kind of of of people socially
different yes it did the social
difference the poor the rich the doctor
the lawyer the working class they are
together this is democracy my children
for example they don't know they don't
have colleagues black Brazilians and
your own the and this is this is
segregation yes and uh well this is a
disaster a disaster and you take a lot
of time to recover yeah a lot of time
perhaps well a century because in very
few years you can destroy what has been
built up Jodie takes a look just like a
war yeah mm-hmm taken yours what
happened in a few years yeah thats a
stir yeah so it happened in South
America in Argentina for example it
happened same thing in Chile and uh
unwell 25 years with no elections we
know packs without practicing democracy
what can can you wait expect of the
politicians
we have we had chance we had who had not
been so it's almost a miracle almost a
miracle I don't believe in miracles but
but the election of President Kennedy
kados Lula II dis lady Dilma Rousseff
were very impressive because it could be
much much worse much much worse and it's
true that last 20 years Brazil has
conquered some some social inequalities
is now so it's a little reason for hope
but but a result but the problem with
the elite the elite that is now who
didn't personally destroy you know their
d is not their fault that the school
system doesn't work for instance but
what is the problem with the elite that
you have right now don't they how do you
say it there's a love that are feeling
in in all your novels about sort of mmm
not wanting to fleeing where you come
from or not acknowledging your past not
knowing your roots not knowing and their
sense of disorientation that you talk
about is this a problem sort of the the
elite that does not really acknowledge
Brazil in a way or how can you explain
that it's a mentality that comes from
the colonialism hmm it's that is the
question problem constant colonialism to
gain a lot of money without caring with
the people with this deal with the city
with start of the city with the children
can imagine we have five thousand and
six hundreds
city's municipal mayor's yeah mentality
of the majority of these people is
harmful they don't carry the children
most of them with the education of the
children of the Brazilian children no
they they went for them for themselves
come reach it in two years for three
years not become regional life hahahaha
this is mentality of of most not all of
course there are good politicians they
are good good people in power but most
of them there's a fight i think that you
know i can give you an example just one
example in my city my house where half
of the population lives a chance down
half 1 million inhabitants live in a
shanty towns favelas a former governor
built I Stajan football football say hey
Joe yeah it costs about five hundred
millions dollars and there was a stage
in very good stage for 1400 people and
the new stations was built for 40
hundred thousand people the same and why
they decide to build the stage the ship
back has a song called criticizing G in
the browser stranded throws a choice mmm
tin help me the dinner brother brother
the shadow with the shadowy transactions
right now exactly this is the problem of
Latin America yeah and this is a rope
shown and better demonstrations and
all this this Ganesh shows it's it's
difficult to and that's why people was
protesting yeah and you have heard about
the demonstration does not against the
president it goes against everything all
this mess all this kind does all this
mentality and no but I'm not the present
not at all well you should love
sometimes and be ironic because and you
should fight I guess everything I work
in a NGO yes in the Amazon that works
with with the education of children in a
small village in the Amazon just to
build small very small libraries you are
in a library but it's very modest 170
libraries they have built and children
that had never seen a book and now they
are reading and they are they are happy
they can think in the future somehow and
there are a lot of people working this
angel she's in some owl but it's a nets
and all the legal amazon region it's a
wonderful work so we have to do that
yeah there I remember a quotation from
orphans of El Dorado where there's a
young man who wants to ok I think
brothers an older man wanting and a
young man to become a politician to
stand for mayor or stand for the City
Council and the young man says well what
party should I run for and the old man
says oh that doesn't matter the
important thing is that you win
and that's a that's a mentality and
that's what we heard yeah this is did
it's very real very very let's see
that's the big problem not to sink in a
collective cultiva t it said because
they have to dl it has to to go out with
bodyguards had they live in in big house
with just like a fat fortress yeah it's
not a kind of life but think changes
history chance mmm I hope and will there
be a sort of progress that does not
destroy a growth or a progress or a
future that does not destroy the past
does not destroy the beautiful buildings
or the rainforest or the lives of
peoples and how do you see the future I
don't see I cannot foresee it's
impossible for me I think about the past
and on the present time that's my just
talk about to write about the past but
battle at same time in the past bring
the past to to to to our time because it
makes sense if you if you write about
the past time but but how to say only if
you talk dialogue with the present and
to understand the present you should you
should understand the past yeah if you
don't know anything about colonialism
you can't understand South America
weekender Stan this mentality why for
example ninety percent of almost all the
black people in Brazil they are they
cannot they are not doctors they are not
lawyers they are not they have bad
schools but since a century ago the
slavery is finished bite but the
Republic and the very beginning till all
the 20th century didn't carry them to
understand this why another day my son
my 10 years old son asked me why all the
pores are black how can I answer so a
boy yeah I should talk about slavery
about the story of the Republican in the
twenties last century and this is this
is history explains a lot of things yes
it's difficult to even announce the
decadent the king of the city when Harry
week on the bridge botanist Robert hobo
man stole stole roads yeah thousands of
seeds of Amazonian the Missoulian rubber
rubber tree area Brazilians and he
patted in in kew garden and then in Asia
and for 40 years later the economy of
the region was was down this is called
do I ritory
it's not a popular figure in in Brazil
its hated in the school of the Amazon
the professor of history's the teacher
of history's the first thing do you know
how the Amazon cracked now no so you
listen this of a hairy mr. Haley weaken
who was hairy weaken a pirate hmm so
these are D when you write a novel you
cannot be naive never unless you write a
very how to say self-help this is not
literature there's another thing and
actually what's so beautiful about your
novels is also i think that that there
are about the power of literature there
about the power of art and also
discussing in this novel what is art
what should art be there's an older
artists who is accused of selling out
and becoming a paintings factory and as
a young artist who is criticized for not
making art this is just provocation this
is not art it's nothing it's provoking
it's it's not art so there's a lot about
what is art really and also the power of
literature in in the two other novels
there are the beautiful passages where
where love is conquered thanks to poems
in the brothers there's a person
reciting Arab the gases to conquer of
the love of a young to get the love of a
young woman and in the orphans of El
Dorado there's there's a cover fees yeah
Boing mmm collapse blame ya yes I was
inspired by this point yeah of kibosh
so so when you read your novels you are
reminded of the power of literature yes
because I think that books talk about
books mm no in fact who we are trying to
write again stories that were told some
day before and that's why we did that we
read the classics and and there are a
lot of flow Barre in my book songs and
go off I stole many things i borrowed
affection I borrowed a lot of things and
this is literature it's a kind of
renovation of a myth is always the myth
that not really a myth because myth is
our is a response but myth is the point
of the off of departure we will open the
floor for questions in five minutes
approximately but we decided that we
would end by one more passage read from
the novel to hear the style of the novel
and I'm reminded of there's a French
teacher in the other novel the brothers
who says to his students well politics
is important but politics is for the
break in class we have higher things to
discuss and that is literature
literature and art so we decided to read
a passage from from from the beginning
of the book from the first third of the
book we talked about reading it only in
Danish but I'm having second thoughts
and I actually think if you would like
to you should make no no second thoughts
they always stick with them okay
so I'm going to read in danish and mundo
and larval are on a riverboat far out in
the jungle and they meet another boat
they're going with with women whose
father who is called Raja know who is a
very rich businessman and has good
friends and connections in the military
and I should mention also that the
person called Macau is the chauffeur and
yeah the chauffeur of the of the
moonless father chauffeur and the
skipper you could say laying off heimer
they were fluent up resist talking teddy
screw up on Chuco take the floor plan or
scorn of a loose una not in plane SI les
miserables shall see later lejos de ma
musique besides lang something
heightening a loon in amid its own anus
on places and in not work or even if you
skip silentium spotted in quantico
mistaken stone fest put in horror flu
bug de Lucas Macau a truce in Atlanta
been captain then put a motor stopped
Ezra no less yelburton Davila shaped
[ __ ] when Michael privy inflict a year
but what if you buy and build is a
wonderful another vigilant bill in store
boo yeah potato peeling layers como esta
Rafael Randall the victory Fork I on
Apple in the shape for the hendon or in
a design novena but I'm gettin da Mousa
for stem john kimble a new lady movie on
conveyor or say select out till within
the water bowl traveling by uno
bournemouth wikipedia on Sophia me genre
will
games ik houd mandava in the hope to
pour homme moon do contain the same give
up august sander and vicetone who made
classy huntin and smile i'm a debate
ahmed tuning anna baham so many
lightning goggles Hornet and 6a utenti
motivational applauding coin secured
with me de tiempo poster 92 hanging Cara
enters it full and Sigma escape head
skilled hero thought was mucho gusto
says Santa come here or Jean oh what a
pass certain mill that's more slit in
vectorize kasie hunt enforcement Macau
is important didn't have a real pool and
shave Lena's are prevailing a so certain
sprang up ortega up to meet if a tragus
at made more hang with nepean in the
stoniest mundo by shorts a t-shirt
normal dude I got her a low anything
Lizabeth ban when so eldri lindsay
anthem is in ville vox new poster 11
bespoke ian when clack of regular family
pay for on him in case it less than n a
new elevators on it ain't seen him sad
laying in her [ __ ] on certain yamen upon
PE he tenses hit me logo or no mundo se
Nikita and the pins Naga school obits
and aloof to see classic el tipo vinton
to our wisdom in hontiveros Janet own
home you seek Mehrotra mirrors lukna
plant been seen and Swedish geology my
son via hands miss I'm sworn will occur
for named and vanity provocation he
certain specialist macau togo became a
hidden small in the earlier and susan
through our winter autumn outcome in
vent cleaning for sale of loot England
nepean forecaster or nested but after
until sunday the impervious is medicine
pile for Boston's mayor Sloan later up
Lauren cargo too hot fat fat yarn comme
une deux sudden diarrhea sorry gimmick
crime you wanna carry the optimal to
approach am tob NCT Macau is a convict
under the water I information for you on
it e is luda diagnose a 0 Boston surgeon
who some start at you owe me today at
Reggie midseason
multiples or railing i casted up
multiple says Sauerland started an arm
new carton fing avail a pile moose and
[ __ ] Oh Boston hodgson opposite a pea
centers on wood him porn ability Bowen
fianza we're seeking for stubble or pins
and 60 steady soon if the moon brewski